[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv
i'm cindy you the spectators broadcast
editor and host of the fortnightly
chinese whispers podcast
on this week's show is the government in
hot water over its measly education
budget
to help students catch up post pandemic
it's not a great look that boris
johnson's own personally appointed
catch-ups are
resigned merely hours after the new
funding was announced
and it's june 21st under threat after
all
also on the show has the national trust
forgotten its founding mission
in its desperation to join the culture
wars and can love grow meat ever replace
the real thing
but first up this week china well and
truly closed the chapter on the one
child policy
the notorious population control regime
was implemented in 1980
and in place for decades before being
changed to the two child policy five
years ago
and the three child policy this year
i've written about the change in this
week's spectator
it was after all because of the one
child policy that my mother and i moved
to the uk so that she could give birth
to my brother
her second child these days beijing is
more concerned about an aging population
holding back its rise
than a population boom it can't feed
china is aging and at an incredible pace
it's estimated that by the end of this
decade the chinese population will start
to decline
and by 2050 two in five chinese will be
over 65.
economists and beijing and policymakers
alike are concerned about what this
means for china's consumption-led
labor field economic rights but
are they right to be concerned i'm
joined by gideon rackman
chief foreign fs commentator at this
financial times who argues that
perhaps not gideon welcome to spectator
tv
first perhaps just outline for viewers
the well-trodden articles about why
aging demographics
and a declining population could be a
problem well i mean historically
it has been countries
have tended to rise when they've had
population booms to become more powerful
and that the concerns about shrinking or
aging populations
are kind of two or threefold
one is that uh the the economics of it
what they call dependency ratios that if
you don't if
if the working age population is
relatively small
and it's supporting a lot of old people
um that can be a big drag on the economy
that's a relatively kind of contemporary
concern simply because of the
extension of life expectancy um you know
i think that uh
when bismarck introduced the old age
pension in germany in the 19th century
people
generally survived like two years and
then they died
and now they might survive 40 years as
pensioners and that's a bit of a problem
um but i mean also i think more crudely
you know when nations went to war and
the crucial thing was armies that you
could deploy
having a lot of warm bodies to put on
the battlefield mattered so that uh
you know the france's kind of rampage
under napoleon was
preceded by a century-long population
boom
um and equally by the 20th century the
french were
very very anxious about um the fact that
germany's population and britain's
population
had exceeded theirs and they had all
sorts of pro-natalist policies to try to
encourage people to have
more children but um historically that
has been really quite hard
and i think china may find that uh now
if
it tries to reverse these trends that
they're difficult
but you know perhaps we can get onto
this i mean i think that some of those
traditional concerns
uh perhaps no longer apply now um
in the same way they did how so can you
explain a little bit more because
clearly people in beijing
are concerned
yeah i mean well i i think the sort of
militaristic concerns are less
opposite now i mean obviously it helps
to be you know china's power does to
some extent stem from the fact that it's
a huge country 1.4 billion people
and so on and therefore is you know
ability to sort of overwhelm a smaller
neighbor
uh you know south korea's odds of in a
war against
china would be small because of the
population gap but i think increasingly
you know we don't really
understand the nature of modern warfare
in the tech age yet because we haven't
had a full-blown war but
if you look at say what the british are
doing um partly because admittedly we're
having difficulty recruiting people
into the army um but increasingly
they're cutting the size of the army and
investing in technology
and there was a very intriguing uh
recent conflict between
armenia and azerbaijan which was
essentially
decided as far as i can tell by unmanned
drones
um so increasingly
wars if they even fought may be decided
by technological sophistication rather
than
just share manpower um the economic
concerns are harder to dismiss
um because uh
you know dependency ratios are difficult
but i i suspect that also that
increasingly since the number of jobs
that people have to do
uh the kinds of jobs that people have to
do are less dependent on physical force
and more on mental capacity um
you know a lot of people will be able to
continue working much longer than we
than we used to uh anticipate um
and uh so it may not be this sort of
huge drag on the economy
that people think on the other hand you
know we are actually seeing you know
a kind of live experiment being run in
east asia
so the population of japan what's
happening in china
is quite distinctive because of the one
china policy but even countries that
didn't have one china policy like south
korea
and japan are already seeing their
population shrink
and age because of people's responses to
you know all sorts of things the nature
of a modern economy the emancipation of
women
and so for whatever reason the south
koreans and the japanese have incredibly
low
replacement rates and the you know it
almost looks like
if you extend the line way out to the
distance japan would simply disappear i
mean its population is going from
i think it's like 120 million now
to about 100 million by 2050 and it
could be as low as
you know 70 million by 2100 um
and we really just don't understand how
that would would work out
or whether they would um you know there
may be changes in demography but once
these things are locked in
and you have fewer and fewer children
and the population begins to shrink
that then you get a sort of uh cycle
where obviously the trend
intensifies one thing you could do is
have
um mass immigration which tends to be
the kind of
european and american solution but
politically contentious even here
and not something that east asian
societies
have been in favor of uh historically no
certainly not in japan and i can't
imagine that working
out very well in china anyway because
the idea of citizenship that is so
ethnically based and you do see for
example the hundreds of thousands of
african students who are
in uh south of china at the moment and
they get a lot of anti-black racism at
the moment
um so i can't imagine china is the sort
of melting pot
or tries to be the melting pot that
britain prides itself on being for
example
no i don't see it see it either i mean
you know it was interesting when i was
in japan
talking to um to japanese officials who
were trying to loosen immigration laws
uh because of the concern that they need
to cut the economy needs labor
um but the things that they regarded as
incredibly radical
were still unbelievably draconian from
european
points of view you know they they they
were allowing workers in but not
allowing their families in
and you know stuff that would just be
very very hard to
to get away with in in your in europe
but you know even speaking to
some of the you know top people in the
ldp the japanese
governing party they would express
privately attitudes that were
um you know quite startling to western
ears you know about
the kind of fear of actually chinese
immigrants and
and uh the clinton you know their claim
that they were sort of
dirty and bringing diseases etc etc
there was quite a really visceral thing
about you know we really don't want to
um import this and although as you say
and as i've indicated i think there is a
strong racist element to it
you know they also look at western
societies and say
you also we pride our societies on
harmony
uh and so on and they're very peaceful
and you seem to have all this kind of
racial tension
around black lives matter or before that
islamist terrorism
and no thank you very much you know
we're going to stick with homogeneity
and you know that is a valid political
choice but it does have
economic and demographic costs that go
with it
and not to mention with the ethnic
minority or already in china for example
the uyghur population which we don't
have time to get into right now but you
know just
going back to demographic problem other
methods for example increasing the
retirement age or this dependency ratio
that you talk about
those issues those policies those
reforms could be politically dangerous
for the
chinese communist party because when
you're talking about increasing
retirement age for example that's
actually unpopular with both the old
because they have longer to work for and
the young because they have more people
to compete with in the labor market so
this is a really important time for the
party to get
right and if they don't people can be
pretty pretty annoyed i mean i i report
in in my article this week that
the response of the three-child policy
wasn't celebration that people had more
freedom to have more children
it was how do you expect us to bring up
these children with the economy as it is
at the moment with living costs as they
are yeah absolutely and i think that's a
particular problem for the communist
party
in that it doesn't admit error it
doesn't even admit error by
previous generations you know they're
about to celebrate the 100th anniversary
of the foundation of the communist party
and the story that xi jinping wants to
tell
is of this sort of triumphant progress
where the party
guides the nation towards greatness and
now clearly
implicitly they're saying the one child
policy was a horrible mistake
um but they can never explicitly say
that and i think that
potentially makes people quite angry uh
you know that
and also undermines this this idea that
okay this time we've got it right and of
course the western
ears one should uh the surprising thing
is well why don't you let people decide
for themselves you know why do you have
to
instruct people one two three you know
it's it's such a personal choice
although i thought there's a very good
point you made in your article for the
spectator this week that
uh you know when this one child policy
was introduced
uh it got a lot of approval in the west
and as i think you wrote the washington
post praised it and so on
because a lot of this demographic
alarmism about uh too many mouths to
feed and
etc etc was coming out of the west and i
think the chinese responding
were responding to um
research and fashionable intellectual
trends in the west when they introduced
the one china policy so we're not
entirely
innocent in all of this but we would
never have been able to go for that kind
of draconian
uh control so yeah i think implicitly
it's part of massive unknowable about
china which is
what do people really think how much
content
this content or discontent is there with
the party
how will it be channeled how will it
express itself these are you know
fascinating questions on which the
future
of china and probably you know
indirectly the future the world hangs
but
you know as you say you can uh look at
what's being said on social media and
maybe on some of these social topics
it's easier to be critical of the party
or to express discontent
indirectly than on something that's
directly political like
xi jinping's you know policies in
xinjiang or hong kong or whatever way
you would just never be able to really
express dissent
yeah it's quite interesting what you
were saying that that that there was
open discussion that it wasn't closed
down very quickly
um so um
yeah i mean and also i mean again i'm
sure you you know more about this than i
do but i
i have this interesting sense that
although
here in the west we tend to portray
china's this incredible booming economy
land of opportunity
amongst young chinese there is a sense
that's a bit reminiscent of what you
hear from young people here in the west
immense career pressure immense
competition to get into university
to get that job then can you afford the
house or the
property in in a big city um sort of
crushing pressure the whole way along
uh which is again not what you'd expect
in a country where
supposedly horizons are expanding
enormously
but i guess you'd have a similar
argument about you know snowflake
generation because you know the previous
cultural revolution generation you know
experienced
suffering and lacks of lack of
opportunities that would be unimaginable
to to to young chinese who face a
completely different set of sort of
pressures
well yes exactly and one of the comments
that i found when trawling through
chinese social media
this week for this for this article was
someone saying 996 is the best
contraceptive
now people in the west won't know what
996 is but there's this new
working regime which is 9 a.m to 9 p.m
six days a week now that started in
china's tech sectors
but it's very fast spreading to other
white collar industries as well and
i don't see how anyone can have three
children on that kind of
time scale and gideon just finally what
does all this mean for china's rise so
much of it has been based on its
economic prowess
and not to mention the party's own
legitimacy if
the demographics do constrain that or if
they don't
do you think that china's rise could be
stunted
well that's a huge question i mean
certainly those in the west who are a
bit
to use the technical term freaked out by
china's rise
have often pointed to the demographics
as something to
kind of cling on to from the western
point of view that ah you know china
will
will get old as they say before it gets
rich that they that they still
uh don't have the per capita wealth
levels close to the united states
and now they're hitting this demographic
wall but you know
that may have implications for personal
wealth um and for how long
china can keep growing at eight percent
but you've got to remember that this is
a country that
you know even with these demographic
projections uh
will probably the population will remain
sort of stagnant for a while
and will be well over a billion people i
mean along with india easily the largest
country in the world
also a country that has you know
enormous now military prowess the
in sheer numbers of ships they're not
necessarily sophistication the chinese
navy
is larger than the united states navy
already
and um and also increasing technological
sophistication
uh you know there are areas of
technology where china leads the world
mobile payments they're very advanced in
ai and other things
so you know the fact that they're now
sort of
walking up a demographic incline if i
can put it that way that they're pro you
know the speed of progress will be
slowed by
these demographic trends it'll happen
relatively slowly and meanwhile
there's so many other things that china
has going for it
uh uh some of the ones i i've mentioned
but also you know in
continuing urbanization will be a driver
of economic growth
that unless there's a huge political or
geopolitical
shock both of which are possible i think
it's it's
it's pretty um unlikely that these
demographic trends will mean that oh you
know
the the rise of china is all off guys
you can relax you know western dominance
is is back it's that's not going to
happen i mean i think sorry guys
that that china's rise has happened
really
and and has still got quite a long way
to go gideon rachman thank you for
joining spectator tv
if you enjoyed that discussion allow me
a little plug for the spectators chinese
whispers podcast
it's my fortnightly podcast taking a
look at chinese history
society politics just search for chinese
whispers wherever you get your podcast
from is completely free
now this week the government announced
1.4 billion pounds of extra funding to
help students catch up
as a pandemic recovery fund but within
hours of the announcement the catch-ups
are appointed by boris johnson kevin
collins
had resigned so what happened i'm joined
now by james forsyth our political
editor
and katie balls our deputy political
editor so james
what's this row about well i think this
row
is a sign of the political phase we're
moving into which is
the the the clearing of the coveted
backlogs there is this tension which is
there are huge backlogs in education
with lost learning
in health with longer waiting lists for
surgery and in the criminal justice
system of cases not having yet
come to court and kevin collins was
saying
look you've got to spend lots of money
now and quickly
to catch up this lost learning so you
don't have a generation that are
unfairly disadvantaged by covet
you've got the treasury saying hang on a
second uh the public finances have been
hit hard by covid
so we need evidence that all of these
interventions are
going to work and trying to kind of uh
to to
to slow down some of the spending uh and
i think that
is what the tensions kevin collins
wanted about uh 15 billion
uh he got 1.4 billion and and he has
quit in protest
and presumably this is fertile ground
for labor to attack on james
yeah it's a kind of classic it allows
labour to say
they're letting down the children which
is always a post and political attack
line
i think the other thing you'll see labor
try and do is they will try and argue
that
children in the north are lost out on
more schooling because their
areas are one of more local restrictions
and the like uh
than than students in the rest of uh
england and so i think you'll see labour
try and say oh this shows that leveling
up is just rhetoric when it comes down
to it they are still the same old tories
and i think you this is that i mean i
think this is going to be politically
a much more difficult phase of the
pandemic in some ways for the government
because
the public there is the labor will play
on this idea but you know
the government found money for testing
for furlough for business supports
so why can't you have buy money to help
students catch up with their lost
learning
well that while the treasury's trying to
argue look we are out of the immediate
crisis phase
so you know you need to restore some
sanity to the public finances
katie is rishi sunak entering his own uh
potential crisis phase throughout this
pandemic he's been known as the
guy who gives out the money but now he
wants to tighten the purses
i don't think it's a moment of crisis
but it's definitely a more difficult
period for the chance though
we've had a period where ultimately soon
it was at one point in last year the
most popular politician in the country
and there are various theories going
around as to why that was
his uh twitter graphics and the fact
that he is a values politician spoke
lots of values and but i didn't even get
around the fact that he was also a
politician who was spending
billions in terms of keeping the economy
afloat and
as we get to a point where he wants to
show more fiscal restraint
and as departments go through their
covert backlog he has to be the voice
which is saying well
actually you might need to think twice
about spending this bit and it is going
to become more difficult for him
james could the government steal u-turn
on this at the time that we're
recording on thursday nothing has
happened yet but it wouldn't be the
first time that the uten or something to
do with education
well yeah on wednesday when boris
johnson hosted a bunch of children in
downing street for a kind of photo op
he was saying you know that there might
be more coming i think one of the
arguments that the treasury was making
was look
you know now isn't the right time to
hand out this money should be handed out
in the spending review in the autumn
when you look at all the other
uh demands on governments uh for for
cash
and so i would be very surprised if
there wasn't some more money in the
autumn for schools and for catch-up
but i would but i equally would be
surprised if it was
of the kind of 15 billion pounds that
kevin collins is talking about
but i guess the problem with autumn is
that kevin collins is saying that that
would be a new school year and
six months taken out would be quite a
long time for children who are already
behind and katie there's a theory going
around in westminster that
all of this new money might come after
gavin williamson has left the education
post because boris johnson wants someone
new to have that glory
what do you make of that theory i think
we've had so many theories going around
in the past year about how gavin wanted
everyone's about to leave his job yet
he's still in his job that i think we
should take them all
and all reshuffle speculation with a
pinch of salt and i think
there is a chance boris johnson
reshuffles his cabinet
and there was some talk of a summer
reshuffle then it becomes an autumn
reshuffle some say oh actually it won't
be till next year
and so i think rather than this being
about putting a new education secretary
in there and then giving them a positive
spin early on by
providing the the money i think it's
more likely as james touched on to me
about the various um
spending reviews how the treasury you
want to go about this because
for all the talk that gavin williamson
should resign because we're getting
cause of that again
and he's probably the secretary of state
that i think has faced those calls the
most of anyone during this pandemic
and i think that if you if you speak to
people behind the scenes and also just
look at some of the reports already out
there
i think gavin williams was much more
sympathetic to this high spend
proposal which came from the now
departed catch-up chief
um than both the chancellor and the
prime minister were now that's not that
surprising it's his department he
obviously wants money for it
but the idea that government is working
against that person
in terms of pushing for funding i think
is false and katie
i think you've mentioned on a podcast
before for coffee house shots you know
it doesn't hurt the government to make
it seem as if a reshuffle might be
around the corner
anyway yes i mean if you want people to
be well behaved i think
the saying is the prime minister is
never more powerful than just before a
reshuffle so
by that logic if everyone constantly
thinks it's just before a reshuffle
you ought to have a very well behaved
tory party and
however i think if we look across the
landscape we're talking about education
funding right
at the moment i wouldn't say there's
that high level of discontent amongst
tory mps on this in part because they do
think more money is coming
and but we are seeing uh you know future
rares likely when it comes to the
department of health department of
justice probably similar debates
and also a rebellion uh brewing on
foreign aid so
the party i would not say is you know
completely united right now there's lots
of people pushing
yes well not least because some of them
are quite worried about this june 21st
date which is the other thing
on the government's mind this week um
james and katie just stay with us for a
second because i'm just going to go to
kate andrews the editor of our daily
lunchtime briefing email
which is the only roundup that you'll
need for the latest covert
stat and analysis so kate just give us
your numbers for now
thanks cindy as the countdown to the
21st of june ticks along
the debate is escalating as to whether
or not freedom day should be delayed
nicholas sturgeon upped the ante this
week when she announced a pause to
unlocking much of scotland's central
belt
a move she insists is not a step
backwards but simply more cautious
approach to the gradual easing of
restrictions
meanwhile some scientists have begun to
warn of a possible third wave
as the daily infection rate has started
to rise
as you can see from this first slide the
seven day average remains nearly 95
below the peak but that small uptick in
recent days is what has the more
cautious block of the scientific
community growing louder
in their calls to abandon the 21st of
june they warned that even this summer
you could see a situation
spiraling out of control but there are
some outstanding questions here
one of them being whether or not the
link between infections and
hospitalizations has been broken
by vaccines you can see here
hospitalizations across the uk remain
roughly 97
below their peak deaths 99
of course hospitalizations lag
infections
and some are arguing don't risk it if
infections are going up
cut them off now with a host of measures
but given how effective the vaccines are
currently thought to be in preventing
severe illness
there's also a real possibility that
more infections won't necessarily lead
to anything like the scenes we saw
in the first two waves it's a question
that may be answered in the coming weeks
right when the decisions around the 21st
of june need to be made
there are some very early certainly not
conclusive signs that can give us some
hope
hospitalizations in bolton where the
indian variant took hold
have started to plateau as you can see
here in recent days
infections as well have started to fall
you can see from this chart that
the over 60s group the vast majority of
which
have now had their first and second
doses of the vaccine
has seen cases per 100 000 remain much
lower
than the younger age groups really
important in terms of testing
effectiveness of vaccines
but also these are the groups that would
be much more likely to end up badly
affected
if they caught the virus this graph also
raises another outstanding question that
we're hoping to get answers too soon
how much more transmissible is the
indium variant compared to other strains
officials think this could be key to
confidently reopening
while three and four adults in england
wales and northern ireland are now
thought to have antibodies
what might happen if this last quarter
of people are exposed to a version of
the virus more likely to spread
this is where things get a bit dicey for
the government in their strategy
once again in this crisis i find myself
asking why we don't know exactly which
data sets the government is following to
make their decisions
much more emphasis has been put on the
second doses since april
partly because of some supply issues but
then mainly because they wanted to give
the fullest protection possible
to the most vulnerable from the indian
variant makes complete sense
and would suggest rightly a focus on
hospital numbers
which we were told at the start of the
crisis was the major concern
by our calculations as you can see in
this graph we are on track to see all
over 50s offered their second dose of
the vaccine before the 21st of june
a huge accomplishment which would see
the utmost vaccine protection given to
those who are most likely to be
hospitalized
or sadly die yet there's been a pivot in
recent days to talking about the
infection rate instead
this isn't just a shift in emphasis but
might also require a different strategy
if you want to get infections down then
it might require you to speed up the
amount of first doses you're giving out
to try and cut some transmission amongst
younger age groups
of course the government would like to
do both we saw incredible pictures in
twickenham this past weekend of
teenagers and
early 20s running to secure their
opportunity to get a vaccine
getting as many jabs into arms as
possible is clearly the goal
but as we get quite close to the 21st of
june now the government may need to
start doing what has been
loath to do in this pandemic lay out
exactly what risks they are and aren't
willing to take
and no doubt if the date is delayed
boris johnson is going to be facing
major questions in his own party
as to what went so badly wrong back over
to you cindy
thank you kate um now james is the
government wavering on that june 21st
deadline a bit more than they were a few
weeks ago
so i think the indian variant has
obviously put june 21st under pressure
i would still be very surprised if the
legal limits
on the numbers of people present at
gatherings didn't go on june 21st i
think the more interesting question is
what happens to uh social distancing so
the one meter rule
mask wearing the work from home guidance
and foreign travel that that that is
where i think the government that's when
the biggest argument will be
and the biggest argument i think of
those will be over the one meter rule
as long as that is in place lots of
pumps and restaurants will have to
operate
below capacity and that will make it and
that will mean that more of them go to
the wall frankly
but if you were to remove the one meter
rule you know
that would have a big impact you see a
lot more mingling a lot more social
interaction
and so there is this is probably the
remaining measure that has the biggest
economic impact but also the biggest
impact on the on the r number
and katy the data seems inconclusive for
now and the
prime minister has said that we need to
wait and see a bit more
but if numerous government advisors have
been on the airwaves this week
talking about extending the june 21st
deadline
of various broadcasters i mean that must
be annoying at number 10 for to have
scientists kind of preempting their
decision
um i don't think it is uh appreciated
by many ministers and figures in in
downing street and beyond when it comes
to the fact that we had a bank holiday
weekend
the prime minister was busy getting
married and he had various uh advisors
to the government
of which there are a lot so one
advisor to the government on science is
one of many that
is not in the same sense for secretary
of state um
and and ultimately filling the airways
of warnings about how he could be in a
third wave
about how you might need to delay and
also having various time frames for this
and that didn't go unnoticed i think in
terms of where this goes
any of you cut through the noise there
are certain advisors the government
leans on more than others
and i and i think we do keep hearing
that it is too early to tell but
i think what's interesting it's a point
that james has written about before
which is
both sides really in this debate so the
doves versus the hawks believe that time
will really show that their argument is
the right one
i think the dubs because they think
cases will keep rising and that will
point to exponential growth
and then i think the hawks because they
think the more time you have the more
you'll see the critical thing which is
that what they hoped to have happened
which is that vaccines would have
severed the link between cases
and hospitalizations and deaths and i
think if you can show that has happened
then high cases are less of an issue
and katie finally you wrote a very
interesting blog on coffeehouse this
week about this topic
but i thought there was interesting that
at the end you mentioned that some
ministers might want
restrictions to be over in the summer
because they might have to come back in
the autumn
so i'll be facing another autumn winter
lockdown potentially
yes i'm really struck by this when i
speak to some figures behind the scenes
and they are talking about how
you get as many restrictions as possible
over the summer where
ultimately the conditions most lean
towards making that easy to do the fact
that
while we finally have some weather which
isn't raining and people
are more willing to hang outside we know
there is much lower transmission
and as we saw last summer the cases
really went down and there's also less
pressure in the nhs
tends to be over the summer and and
therefore just
by logic of this if things go a bit
wrong
if you have booster jabs if there are
new variants
and they're much harder to face going
into the autumn and winter
than going into the summer and therefore
i do think that it's not a definite but
there is a
contingency discussions going on about
bringing in a few measures now i don't
think anyone thinks this is going to be
a lockdown but it could be the case for
example
that we get rid of the one meter rule
and face masks in most places over the
summer
and then if the figures start to worry
the government and they were over nhs
capacity
which is under more strain and autumn
and winter there was a push to bring a
couple of those measures back
and i think that's why it's interesting
when we're talking about delaying things
over the summer
and that lots of people lodged in their
mind once things have gone they're never
coming back and
unfortunately i am not quite so
convinced by that
james and katie thanks very much next
i'll be speaking to charles moore the
spectator's former editor about what's
going wrong with the national trust
but before that i'm contractually
obliged to tell you about the
subscription offer that we have
if you enjoy the coverage from spectator
journalists that you've seen in this
episode
you can get more of it through a
subscription to the magazine it's 12
weeks for 12 pounds and we'll even throw
in a free amazon gift voucher
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash tv offer
and you can read fantastic analysis from
kate andrews james forsythe katie balls
and more online and imprint
now has the national trust forgotten its
founding mission
an organization the biggest in the world
of its kind set up to preserve british
history artifacts and
architecture seems to be ashamed of its
properties
or in a bid to join the culture wars
charles moore former editor of the
spectator and columnist for the
telegraph
writes this week's cover article broken
trust and joins us on spectator tv now
charles welcome to the show it's been an
understandably difficult year for
organizations like
the national trust because of covert but
you're writing about a different
phenomenon
yes uh and of course covert made it
worse because they decided to do what
they did
at the same time as dealing with
horrendous and uh
inevitable problems about kovid
so they sort of entered the culture war
last summer when they
produced their um report or so-called
interim report on
slave slavery and what they call
colonialism in its connection with
national trust properties and so they
opened
a tremendous um storm of argument
and it wasn't a good report it was very
politically motivated
it wasn't terribly accurate and it made
a false conflation
between slavery and empires if they were
absolutely empires automatically as bad
as slavery as and so on
and of course this was very disturbing
to members who were already
disturbed by the wider circumstances and
confusing and it was clear that the
motivations
of this report were not the normal sort
of scholarly motivations which should
motivate
a heritage charity but were highly
political and
explicitly so actually and so you had
this feeling
very very difficult feeling for a great
heritage organization that the people in
charge of it actually don't like
their properties and that's very
demoralizing
and uh it makes people feel that the
whole purpose of the
trust which has sustained it for more
than 100 years is being um
undermined what's incredible is that you
mentioned in your piece that
on the panel of people who put together
this report there were no academic
historians and indeed
some of the leading academia surrounding
this very complicated and nuanced
history
weren't cited at all so i mean who did
who did do the report in the end
well the report was mostly written by
national trust
curators and i think that was a
deliberate decision by the trust to show
that their people were endorsing it
and those curators are often very good
at their particular subjects but there's
no special reason why the expert on
textiles
should be able to talk about the
politics of imperial history
um or furniture or whatever it may be
and the
guiding influence behind the report is
who
is professor corin fowler of the
university of leicester
who's not a historian um she's a
professor of post-colonial literature
not on the staff of the trust but
retained by the trust
to help with these matters and she has a
very very clear very hard-line
which she expresses in her book with the
revealing title of green unpleasant land
um in wishing to show that the patrimony
of
britain and particularly england is
a slave um slavery polluted
empire polluted patrimony and therefore
sort of wishes to cast a shadow
over the many beautiful places and
buildings
um and the whole history really which
the national trust
cherishes um i think it's entirely
appropriate
that a body like the national trust
should understand these things and not
try to hide anything
but i think it's quite inappropriate
that it should give a platform
to people who are actually against
the very things it tries to protect
conserve and celebrate
and it even does this in its educational
program so professor fowler
um has this program which the trust is a
national trust program
called the colonial countryside project
in which they take school children 10
year olds
round houses that they say are linked
with slavery
or what they call colonialism and invite
the children to have a look at it and to
write creative writing which of course
because the children sort of know what's
expected of them is
very very hostile um to the places and
sometimes to the
um occupants the former occupants of the
places who often actually gave their
properties
to the trust so you have a poem saying
what a
dreadful man lord kirsten was who's one
of the greatest benefactors of the trust
ever
and of conservation in general both in
india and in britain
and so you have this feeling of
hostility right within the system
to what the national trust stands for
and it's not
necessarily um therefore because it's
motivated by that hostility it's not
necessarily learned it's not necessarily
well informed or accurate
lots of things they said were about
winston churchill for example and
chartwell were wrong factually wrong
and um this also is very undermining
uh it's simply not correct um and
of course the millions and millions of
members the membership now declining
uh will worry about that rightly so
so if you were a historian with a
different perspective
you mentioned this campaign group
restore trust
were you consulted because it is a very
nuanced
view on a very complicated and long
history and
i can imagine a lot of these questions
are quite hard to answer you know how do
you say if an economy is
quote unquote based on slavery or
colonialism
when you know everything gets muddled
together quite a bit
did they consult a wide range of
opinions
no i wouldn't i wouldn't say they did
because everybody in the colonial
countryside project
and pretty much everybody in the interim
report
are of only one view um and they
as far as i can see made no effort to
get
wider views i think the way to approach
this subject is
to think more about the whole historical
context of the acquisition of all sorts
of property
by the national trust and why it
mattered what it tells you where it
comes from and so on
and then you will find that
there are all sorts and some of them are
just as controversial as slavery believe
it or not i mean the classic one which
could easily be addressed by the
national trust is the dissolution of the
monasteries in which
um by killing and theft really state
theft
monastic institutions were destroyed the
monks were sometimes hanged
and their property was grabbed by rich
friends who then became richer
of henry viii um now that
could be presented as a tremendous stain
on some of the trust properties such as
a phantom's abbey for example
um but i think a sensible historical
approach to that would not be concealed
it should be told but not to try to work
up a sort of lazar of indignation
about the whole thing the story of
country houses the story of the
countryside is often to do with power
and money and sometimes it's to do with
robbery and violence and that's
important to understand but give it the
full context don't single out
um a couple of things that happen to
obsess you
and also don't link one of them slavery
and empire as
almost identical concepts they're jolly
well not and a great many people who
serve the empire
did very great things in the world i
can't think of anything great about
slavery but i can think of
many great things in the world done by
the british empire and by
imperial servants and one of those great
things by the way was the abolition
of slavery so let's have some nuance
let's have some context let's have some
depth and breadth
and let's also remember that the trust
is about objects and places
it needs to give them their wider
historical context but it is not
a political body it's not about the
history of parliament the history of war
the history of
of um industry all these things
come into it it is about the these
objects these places
um these beautiful landscapes these
beautiful houses and works of art
and that's what it's good at and that's
what it should
maintain with love do you think that
there is more that the national trust
could do when it comes to diversity i
mean the plight of catholic monks
in the middle ages is probably not as
fashionable these days as
multiculturalism and people from various
communities i'm always amused when i go
to the national trust that
my family are the only non-white people
visiting do you so do you think there is
more that the trust could do to
quote unquote use that awful phrase
modernize
well i think that um first of all i
don't think it's surprising because on
the whole
ethnic minority populations still live
more in towns
and are less likely to be close to a
great many uh national trust
properties but i think there's something
perverse going on here
if you start to preach that these houses
are based on iniquity
why would that persuade um
ethnic minorities who are supposed to be
the butt of this iniquity
to come yes very true if you you know if
you
um if you're proud of your heritage
though also honest about it
that's what attracts people of of any
race you know i don't have a problem if
i go to
um if i'm an ethnic minority in india or
whatever when i visit
i want to see the great um
uh examples of indian culture and i
don't have to keep thinking to myself
am i quote uncomfortable that's one of
the words these people love
uncomfortable
here no um i am i'm interested
and but of course i'm not going to be
interested if i'm always um
told how evil it is yes absolutely and
finally because i know we have to let
you go very very
soon there's now a national trust
chairmanship
empty would you throw would you fancy
throwing your hat in the ring
no no i mean um uh i think there will
now be a long process
actually there should be a long process
where they need to think very carefully
and they need to find someone who um
really can recognize how badly things
have gone wrong
and put them right but not i hope in a
terribly confrontational way it's got to
be firm
but it's also got to be healing because
the great tremendous
historical advantage of the national
trust is in its name it's national and
it's trusted
and that trust has been greatly
diminished
in some cases positively broken and
the next people have to really work hard
to restore it
charles moore thanks for coming on to
spectator tv and finally
would you eat meat grown in a lab last
december a world first was created when
a singaporean restaurant
sold a box of chicken nuggets that were
completely lab-grown
so-called cultured meat is the future
and means that we won't have to kill
animals for food in the years to come
at least that's what the mp anthony
brown argues in his article for the
spectator this week
i'm joined now by dr mark cotter from
cambridge and also co-founder
of meetable a company which is on track
to produce cultured pork
in just a couple of years dr cotter
welcome to spectator tv
can you start by explaining to the
layman what cultured meat
means hi cindy thank you very much for
having me on the show
so cultured meat is really the concept
of
creating real meat
in a lab um removing the requirement
of large-scale and animal farming
can you explain what the life process of
that looks like how how do you grow like
meeting a lab so i think we've seen sort
of
meat substitutes become popular in the
past couple of years and these are often
based on plant-based sources
um cultured meat really wants to create
the real thing
the real thing which is consists mainly
of muscle
tissue and and fat tissue
um and remove the sort of requirement of
animal farming do this actually in in a
lab
and the way that this works is that you
use
bioreactors which are you know culture
conditions
uh um that um have the cells floating
in 3d and and allowing them
to grow up and then um you want to
put them into molds essentially
that allow them to grow muscle bundles
and fat tissue i think that would be the
ideal way of doing this
sounds very simple it's actually very
very difficult um
and and there's been sort of slow
pro progress until more recently when
when things really sped up
well that brings me to my next question
actually which is how far away
is this technology i think we made some
leaps uh um recently and
i i can i can tell you about uh the
company that i'm involved in
which is called mutable essentially it
came out
of an invention it was created based on
an invention that
my academic laboratory did together with
professor ludovic's laboratory at the
stem cell institutes in cambridge
um and what this allowed us to do is to
really make this process of creating
these fat cells and these and these
and these muscle cells very very
efficiently that's been really
the bottleneck so being able to create
um specific cell types is not only a
problem
for cultured meat it's also a problem in
other fields like medicine
you know i'm my bet my background is a
medical doctor
so that's that was my primary interest
but we happen to discover a process
that is very very efficient and scalable
and so the idea of meetable is to
to develop this process to create these
uh products
um meat products at scale and how far
are we away
i believe we're going to see first
prototypes
on display um this year and i think
there'll be there'll be a small
production
um in the next two years or so
so i think we're very close this field
has made a huge leap
so by the end of the year we could see
it in supermarkets
on the shelves next to the vegetarian
options this real meat but that hasn't
been
an animal hasn't been killed in the
process no i i i refer to a prototype
so it's a small selective production
that you know
showcases this and allows the regulators
to approve it
very interesting and are there parts of
um meats that you can't replicate so
much
i'm thinking for example um things like
ribs like the bone part of things
is the meat that you create are they
going to be just lumps of meat
essentially so
all those other parts of an animal
presumably you can't replicate that
look what bioengineering um has
provided us uh within the last um
10 years is really tools to to really
think
think big uh and i do think that it's
possible to actually
create something that looks like a bone
3d printing of calcium etc
but let's be pragmatic the first product
that you want to bring into
the market is obviously something that's
very simple to produce
and the simplest products i would say
are minced meat
sausages and things like that but i
think
that already has the potential that a
real step
change in terms of how we think about
meat uh how we think about the origin of
meat
um and also it allows us to open up
a future where you know we are less
less reliant on on on
on the resources that really put a big
strain
on on our on our planet yes and let's
come to some of those pros in just a
second because people might be wondering
you know
why bother but first of all do you think
that this
tastes like meat um i mean i know that
biologically it is but are there parts
of an animal's growing experience all
around the world you hear about you know
grass-fed beef or whatever it is
part of the animal's diet or exercise
that makes the meat taste different
can you do anything about that when
you've only got the dna
well i do think if you that you actually
have even greater flexibility
um if you have something in an
industrial process
so it's much less
left to whatever happens to the outside
i think what i'm trying to say here is
once you apply
an engineering approach to biology and i
think this happens now broadly
uh across various spectra um
then then your your tool set your
abilities actually increase and you can
do
things that you may have not thought
about um
i can think of some really strange
things like
um creating creating
meat from different species and having
it in one
um so so fine tuning a bit like you know
a good wine
or or you could also you know oh
well like a like a meat with a dna of a
pig and a
and a cow and then seeing what that
would taste like that's right having
having those cells together in in in one
in one um you know piece of meat
essentially
hmm interesting i think we'll have to
get get viewers to email in on their
thoughts about that and what
combinations of me
sure i think we're talking about the
future at this point
yeah i think this technology has
has um a chance to address some of the
sort of
real pain points including
including the reason why you know we're
sat
stuck in zoom boxes at the moment and
not being able to travel freely i think
uh
you know intensive farming um
comes with the risk of uh viruses um
transmitting
from from from animals to human
yes absolutely and can you talk a little
bit about the benefits
that you see with with this approach is
one day we won't be have to kill animals
for farming
ever is that right yes absolutely i
think that's uh
one of the drivers animal welfare
considerations i think um on top of my
personal
uh agenda as well um although i do like
meat
i do eat meat so i don't want to sort of
pretend that i'm
a vegetarian at this point in time
the second aspect of course is um you
know the conditions under which animals
are you know raised uh
uh and and slaughtered i think here um
having an alternative is
is really really important
uh another aspect is um the
environmental impact
and also the medical impact of the
current way of producing meat
so we all heard about the use of
antibiotics
in farms and what that means is that
a lot of antibiotics are used across
across the globe which don't
help patients so to speak but make
bugs become more resistant
and we feel the effects of that
in in the clinic we have an increase in
ins in bugs and strains that cannot be
treated
with the regular set of antibiotics
so i think it's key one key aspect of
cultured meat is to be able to
sort of reduce the broad application of
antibiotics
as a doctor that's of course something
that that's really important
and and then there's this other aspect
that
that i think people are becoming more
more aware of
which is really the greenhouse gas um
that
that is emissions that are associated
especially with
uh cattle and
in fact i think it's one of the largest
single
contributors contributors to to
greenhouse gases
um and so having an alternative
in this space i think is also something
um that that is very valuable
and finally we all know that meat's not
always healthy
and and that's sometimes because of you
know
certain fats that are in in in meats
and if you let's go back to this
engineering approach what you could
what you could essentially do is you
know you could take out some of those
non-healthy um you know substances that
uh that we see although i think again
we're talking more about the future
yes of course um and is all of this
safe you know when we come talking about
um gm
foods for example a lot of people's
concerns are that is not safe and what
you're doing is not just mod it's not
modifying genetics obviously but you're
recreating it and you're growing
meat and which could be the main basis
of our diet
is that a safe thing to do to be
consuming i mean let's be honest
uh when we culture meat it's an
artificial process
is is a synthetic process um the
question then becomes
um is the is the product safe or not
and that's essentially so so you know i
think uh
um we just need to recognize that this
is not something that happens without
you know an industrial machine behind it
now the the the the good thing is that
um
we have a lot of experience
um you know our society was regulating
um aspects of food
and aspects of health you know there's a
system that checks every drug that is
developed there's a system that
uh looks at every new food uh that
that's being put out and and i and i do
trust that
um that the robustness of
of these systems um and so i do think uh
if you ever want to create a product
that can be used
it has to it has to jump all the hoops
and
and all the checks um that that are
required to make it a safe product
so i wouldn't feel comfortable at all um
if
we sort of decide if there would be
someone who to decide to go forward with
a product that isn't safe
yes absolutely well it's interesting
that you mentioned the regulators
because
in anthony brown's piece for the
spectator this week he talks about how
the singaporean regulators
have given the green light for something
like this but
in the eu for example there's a bit more
reluctance
and he mentions that in brussels and
washington lobbyists from
the farming industry have made have are
making efforts so that
the word meat can only be applied to
meat that comes from
animals being slaughtered i mean you
must be coming up against quite a lot of
opposition inertia
yeah i i do think if you come with
something
that's a very disruptive idea and
by no way in way i want to claim that
this was my idea i think there's a whole
field out there
but if you're part of something that's
novel
uh you you are going to ruffle feathers
and and and cause some pushback and i
think some of that pushback is
um is good because it um
basically means that you have to up your
game you have to show
uh that uh what what you generate what
you produce is actually better
in in in so many aspects um
i think there's also a little bit of
sort of fear
uh in certain pockets um um
what's interesting though is that um if
you look at
the sentiment of of of the users you
know the man in the street and the women
on the street
that we can see a real swing away from
you know
um from this is
artificial we don't want to touch it to
some
to to a sort of new mindset where people
are aware
of all the problems that our current
system has
and where people decide to become vegan
or vegetarian
not because they don't like meat but
because they don't like the process uh
and and and the animals the wealth
aspects
of it and and this particular sort of
um you know group of people which is
which is large um i believe um
is very in favor for for for a meat
alternative
even though uh it is it is you know
something that comes out of the lab
yes well as a family vegetarian i can
very much get behind that
and i'm intrigued by this idea of the
hybrid sausage
dr mark cotter thank you very much for
joining spectator tv
thank you so much and thanks to all our
guests on this episode and to you for
watching
as ever if you have any feedback please
email spectator tv
spectator dot co dot uk we do read all
of them even if we may not have time to
get back to you
and a final reminder if you enjoyed the
discussion today why not pick up the
magazine or read us online you'll get
more of these same intelligent
contributors
fresh topics and insightful analysis
without bumping into a pay wall
just go to spectator dot co dot e k
forward voucher to subscribe
12 issues for 12 pounds and we'll even
throw in a 20 pound amazon voucher
thanks for watching spectator tv and see
you next week
[Music]
you